Sharks have existed in one form or another
for millions of years.
Just when you thought it was safe to go back
in the water, it was never safe.
It has never been safe!
Hey there street sharks, HOST here for DNews.
Sharks are truly ancient.
There’s some disagreement on when they actually
appeared on the scene, but any way you slice
it, they were here almost 200 million years
before the first dinosaurs.
It’s pretty impressive we can trace their
ancestry back that far, when you consider
that sharks have skeletons made of cartilage,
not bone, which inherently doesn’t fossilize
as often because it’s easier to break down.
In fact the earliest evidence of sharks is
from just a handful of scales found in Colorado
that date back 455 million years.
These scales have a characteristic tooth-like
structure to them that makes us reasonably
certain they were once stuck on something
we would classify as a shark.
The earliest undisputed shark scales are 420
million years old and were found in Siberia.
But aside from their scales, we have no idea
what early sharks looked like.
When you hear “shark” your first thought
is probably of a torpedo shaped superpredator
with rows of teeth like steak knives, but
millions of years ago their shape could have
been something we wouldn’t recognize.
It’s the definition of what makes a shark
a shark that allows for a lot of flexibility.
Sharks must have replaceable teeth, internal
fertilization, paired fins, the aforementioned
cartilaginous skeletons and distinct scales,
and of course, Jaws.
So when the fossil record starts becoming
richer around the devonian period 400 million
years ago, sharks of all shapes and sizes
start popping up.
We’ve found shark teeth that are two pronged
like the “rock on” symbol, suggesting
that they had to eat their prey whole instead
of ripping chunks out of them like they do
today.
Early shark bodies may have been more eel-shaped,
with long tapering tails.
Even when they began looking more familiar,
they were still quite different.
They tended to have long jaws that were at
the front of their heads, and they couldn’t
extend them to catch prey like modern sharks.
There were actually two major adaptive radiations
where shark diversity exploded.
The first was during the carboniferous period
starting 360 million years ago.
Mass die offs of competitors meant sharks
could thrive, and in particular one group,
the stethacanthids, really pushed the envelope
of style.
One stethacanthus species had an anvil on
its back, and nobody's quite sure what advantage
that gave it.
Maybe it was waiting for the hammerhead to
evolve so they could fashion swords together
and create an unstoppable shark army.
Another shark, the Helicoprion (hell-icko-pryon),
appears to have had a buzz saw shaped lower
jaw.
But of course, we don’t see these guys around
today.
At the end of the Permian 250 million years
ago, 99% of marine species died out, including
most sharks.
Some sharks made it through to the other side
though, possibly by sticking to deeper seas
where the water was less acidic.
These sharks were minescule, only an inch
long.
But they would be the start of something big.
By the jurassic period 42 million years later,
they would cause the second adaptive radiation
of sharks, leading to modern sharks as we
know them today.
Sharks have survived through 5 mass extinctions
because they’ve taken on so many different
forms and filled so many niches.
But today their populations are dwindling.
The rate we catch sharks, either intentionally
or as bycatch, is devastating for species
with a low reproductive rate.
And sometimes we intentionally slaughter sharks
in the name of protecting swimmers near coast
lines.
In the last 450 million years, sharks have
seen a lot, but never anything like us, and
many species may not last much longer.
If you want to learn more about what sharks
have become tune into Shark Week which kicks
off Sunday, June 26th 8/7c
Want to know what you can do to stave off
shark extinction?
Tara has a video on that here.
Would you rather swim with one 10 foot long
shark, or 1200 1 inch long sharks?